amsterdam la rouge
depuis une semaine les filles des
vitrines sont officiellement des
travailleuses du sexe les maisons closes
des entreprises comme les autres
redevable des mêmes taxes est soumise à
la même législation du travail
andré mène son affaire théoriquement
illégale depuis 25 ans sans que personne
n'y ai trouvé à redire
pour lui la nouvelle législation va
surtout permettre de faire un peu de
ménage
nous avons toujours travaillé
correctement avec le fisc nous l'avons
toujours laissé faire ces contrôles donc
pour nous il n'y a pas de problème mais
beaucoup d'exploitants n'ont jamais
travaillé de façon acceptable
ils emploient des clandestins ou alors
ils forcent les filles à faire des
choses qu'elles ne veulent pas faire ou
encore leurs maisons sont mal gérées
donc pour moi il doit absolument changer
leurs pratiques ou quitter le métier qui
me travaille à son compte dans
l'établissement à chaque fois qu'elle
montendrais touche 270 francs de
location pour la chambre
le reste c'est elle qui gère
difficilement depuis la nouvelle loi
cette loi c'est un pas en avant et deux
pas en arrière
pourquoi vous avez la chambre de
commerce les un pont les comptables tout
le monde veut savoir maintenant où vous
vivez ce que vous faites et c'est
vraiment difficile
par peur de payer plus d'impôts mais
surtout de perdre leur anonymat beaucoup
de filles se sont envolés aujourd'hui
seuls les majeures et ressortissants de
l'union européenne ont le droit
d'exercer ce n'est le cas que pour la
moitié des 25000 prostituées du pays
objectif de la loi lutter contre le
travail clandestin normaliser la
prostitution volontaire et établir un
nouveau droit du travail
officiellement les clubs n'existait pas
avant cette loi
donc qu'est ce qu'il se passait pour les
prostituées compte elle voulait faire
valoir leurs droits rien on puisse elle
avait peur de s'exprimer mais depuis
qu'elles savent qu'un syndicat le fn
avait décidé de les défendre
elles peuvent aller le voir et dire je
suis une prostituée quels sont mes
droits
hélas elles seront écoutés ça c'est un
grand changement
un changement qu'on attendait ici depuis
bien longtemps une petite boutique
d'information sur la prostitution coincé
entre deux vitrines du quartier chaud
pour mariska ancienne prostituée qui a
ouvert le lieu en 94
légaliser ne règle pas tout je suis
assez en colère contre les autorités
hollandaises
elles ont changé la loi d'accord mais
c'est tout ce qu'elles ont fait on ne
s'est pas préoccupé d'informer les
prostituées ou la société
tout le monde reconnaît que c'est une
profession légale mais comme c'est
encore mal vu d'être prostituées
personne n'accepte de les intégrer
vraiment il aura fallu 18 ans de débat
pour en arriver là mais le flou entoure
toujours des questions essentielles
quelle couverture sociale quel système
de retraite les ministères concernés
n'ont encore rien prévu pour intégrer
dans leurs comptes
le plus vieux métier du monde